disgrace
disgrace and we are the power the people
chant in the center of novokuznetsk
siberia they're answering the call of
the arrested opposition leader alexey
navalny
among them nineteen-year-old activist
anastasia matskibich
we met her the next day at the place
where the protest was held in the city
park
of novokuznetsk
she says she protests against
restrictions on freedom of speech
the lack of perspective and the poor
standard of living in russia
[Music]
i took to the streets for myself and my
family i'm afraid of the police and the
injustice in our country
i live in a russia that wants to stop us
from speaking out
anastasia echoes the sentiment of tens
of thousands of other protesters
the weekend demonstrations swept through
over a hundred cities in 11 different
time zones
in the far eastern port city vladivostok
on the sea of japan
demonstrators demanded a way with putin
while in the industrial city
ikatarimborg in the euro mountains
protesters were beaten back by the
police
and in saint petersburg as many as ten
thousand protesters swarmed over the
city's showcase boulevard
nevsky presbyter
alex navalny himself has been in custody
since his return from germany
in mid-january cut off from direct
contact with the outside world
but the kremlin's vocal critic can still
influence political life
shortly after his arrest the violence
sympathizers released an explosive to
our video
it presented a palatial mansion on the
black sea coast
and maintained that it was built for the
russian president and paid for with
ill-gotten gains
within just a few days the video had
racked up over 90 million views
it may well have been the match that
sparked the flame of dissent against
president putin all across the country
as here in moscow
the video shows how crazy our leaders
are and proves these people must not be
allowed to hold their power any longer
personal enrichment is their only goal
i live with my family in a tiny flat we
are honest people
not thieves but all around us are people
who are
enriching themselves illegally without
anyone saying anything about it
but i'm against it i've had enough
the state is corrupt we earn less and
less money and have hardly any rights
after the mass protests russian
president putin
responded to the allegations of
corruption
what was shown in the video as my
property
belongs to or has ever
is not convinced by putin's statement
she and her friend put greater trust in
opposition figures such as navani
after 20 years of putin they are
demanding a change
in russia's leadership i'm from the
generation putin
i've never known anything else some
people joke that i'll die with putin
still in power
that is rather strange after all we're
not living in the age of the kazaars
where the rulers stayed in power to the
end of their days
we want our country to be ruled in
future by politicians who are elected by
the people
but she says that until free and fair
elections are held in russia
she is prepared to continue her protest
for an honest russia without corruption
for a russia without putin
you